I have to say so between this and we can
be heroes how much does Netflix love you
oh they're just the best even from the
very beginning it was their idea you
know Steve stuber came to me and said I
was pitching him something he goes out
we'll consider that for sure but we
really need is some like a spy kids type
thing those always do so good in our
service I was like that makes a lot of
sense kids would watch movies over and
over on video or on you know Disney
Channel or DVDs but nobody could track
it
how much people watched it on Netflix
they could track it so I gotta make a
movie for my family audience there
because the kids don't have to drive
themselves to the theater they can sit
there and click as many times as they
want and they'll track it and that'll
create value so I did we could be heroes
and it's one of the top movies because I
couldn't believe how many times kids
would re-watch it and then we got the
right Spy Kids and got to go remake the
original Spy Kids uh franchise bring
that back like a bond series so super
excited they're super excited because
you know they want to build up their
family business for sure I'm I'm sure of
it and uh uh one of the things that
watching the film and looking at the
credits it felt like every member of
your family was somehow involved in this
movie was there any members of your
family that were not involved in the
movie oh despite everybody in my
immediate family and they're still you
know over the years and the other spy
kid films
uh worked on them
um so there's always it was always a
family franchise it's the only family
film series in existence that's actually
made by a family for other families and
we wanted to keep that going and now my
kids though
they started off doing stunts and acting
in the first films because they were
little now they're my they're the age I
was when I made Mariachi and Desperado
so they're all one's a composer one's a
co-writer one designs the video game
within it one sings the end titles and
Designs the the Emojis on the thought
bubble so you know they're all given
one's co-edits you know so
um it's like
my favorite families growing up in San
Antonio owned their own family-run
restaurants it all worked there and they
owned it
and I always dreamed about doing that
someday when I guess I just ended up
doing it in the movie business because
it has that feeling where the more time
you spend working on a project it's
family time it's more time you're
spending with your family so it's uh
just the best life and you're putting
all your experiences all your end jokes
so many scenes in the movie are right
out of my childhood or their childhood
and so everybody gets to throw in their
ideas you know I've spoken to you before
you know I love talking about the
editing process so how did this film
specifically change in the editing room
in ways you didn't expect how did it
change
um it's just always a surprise because
when you're working with kids
you don't know till they get there what
they're capable of doing you know you
write a scene you you hire an adult
actor you know there can pretty much do
the scene not with the kids you don't
know which actor is going to be because
they're developing at the same time
they're only eight years old like both
of them at the beginning would be like
um I don't think I can do that and
they'd say well give it a try okay I'll
try see but don't try do it and they're
like by the end they're oh yeah I'm
sorry I'm not going to try anymore I'm
just going to do it you know their
confidence level goes up
and by the end when I see Tony you know
battling with the King it's a totally
different kid than I started out with
these movies they develop so rapidly
because of all the challenges you throw
in and uh I taught me to do that with my
own kids you know like throw challenges
at your children you tend not to at the
level I do they spike is they become
superhuman over a couple of months and
so when you're in the edit room actually
when you're on the set you realize okay
they they're not capable of doing what's
in the script let's come up with
something they can do really well so by
the time you get to editing you're like
how did we change the scene it doesn't
resemble the script at all you got much
better stuff out of them because you
kept honing the script to what their
abilities were and pushing them to do
things you never thought they could have
done uh so it's a discovery process
where you're practically making a
documentary because it's just the script
goes out the window you know
and and it's so fun to edit that way I
have to edit really quickly as soon as
I'm done shooting and while I'm actually
filming I'm I'm editing because I don't
want to forget because I don't have a
script as a guide anymore I was making
up Hulk new choreographies and and
things unlines that they could say on so
it really capitalize on their talent and
uh that's that's a that's really fun
about it one of the things are the kids
grow up very fast and I know this is
going to be a huge hit for Netflix with
the strike being on is is there a plan
that you want to make a sequel to this
like as soon as possible and the same
questions pretty quickly and um but you
really can't film them until the summer
times because the kids have to do
schooling during this no matter what
even if it's summer but they have more
school this at that age at the uh during
the non-summer break and you would you
would only get them for an hour or two
on set so you get them for about four or
five hours on some or breaks it's a
little more uh easier to film them so
that would be great because the first
Spy Kids series we had a movie in the
theater every year for three years
straight for Spy Kids one two and three
they were a consecutive we were just
finishing one and starting the next so
that that would be really great but
unfortunately with these kids we got
them so young they're younger than the
original Spy Kids they're only eight
years old so we've got them for you know
several years the ideal World maybe next
summer filming a sequel that would be
great to give me time to write something
really robust and fun I definitely want
to ask you though about we can be heroes
uh that as you we've talked about huge
hit and you talked about doing a sequel
is is there any plans for that that
would be the most that would be the the
bigger Rush is to do a sequel for that
because of the the kids growing up
although the
the script uh always kind of took that
into account there's supposed to be kind
of a Next Level and I and I like the
idea of kids seeing their favorite
characters grow so exponentially on
screen and it makes them realize how
time works to go oh yeah well guppy was
this age in the first movie I've been
watching again and again and now she's
already you know they can picture
themselves growing and developing and
their brains expanding and Leaps and
Bounds like that so I think that the
time works in our favor my last question
for you um this film has a ton of VFX
and I'm just curious what can you talk a
little bit about doing the VFX on this
one and how it's changed throughout the
years uh with technology I'm still doing
it exactly the same way I've actually
filmed a nice same green screen I filmed
the original on it was trippy
have a lot of my key Crews still there
and we're doing another Spy Kids we're
hanging them on the same wires that the
original ones did over 20 years ago only
this level of effects is just so much
better I mean if you compare them it's
like night and day the level of effects
that uh a Netflix affords you is just a
dream you know for this thing to
actually look like the vision we had in
our heads
I find old drawings from the original
Spy Kids I was going that's what it was
supposed to look like we just didn't
have the money here it just looks
amazing you know they go into that video
game and it only needed to look like a
video game and it looks like they're
really in this locations so yeah there's
over 1600 effect shots there's a ton the
most effect shots in any Spy Kids movie
it is just non-stop but you know kids
that's why kids are gonna love it they
just never see a movie made for them
that's got that level of
you know love and attention put into it
to just fuel their dreams and give them
something to dream about it's totally
going to be a huge hit on that note I
gotta stop I'm just gonna say congrats
sir and you know I wish you nothing but
the best thanks I appreciate that Steve